that's what you want to rap about what
you're not in that section and I said
don't be creepy or sexual and you said a
person who embodies both of that in a
horrendous way so no what would someone
else have ones I'll come to you in a
second what was that fracking Wow
straight up down here who's who said
what you care more about the environment
fracking okay when the gentleman said
Bill Cosby I mean it might it definitely
was a gentleman that said it but what
someone else said something what was it
the rubbing rubbing the Boston Tea pay
[Applause]
for this is just an observation I made I
love drinking tea I genuinely do and
there's it's a very obvious gripe over
here that Americans can't make tea
properly and I was in Starbucks and I
was like they put the water in the glass
and then they put the teabag in rather
than the water on the tea bag and I was
like why do you do that the woman goes
well I guess it goes the lower back to
the Boston Tea Party you put the tea bag
in the water as I shove it too clever
for your own good
I mean obviously that didn't happen
that's a joke I made up right I'm super
clever but imagine if it did happen so
fracking Boston Tea Party let's come see
you guys over here what you want to rap
about the written right now I'm banning
anymore Revolutionary War any kind of no
war that Britain has lost is allowed to
be suggested
you can't suggest any we've got Boston
Tea Party War ixnay on that what did
someone else say the Hubble telescope I
wish I'd taken Revolutionary War now but
Hubble telescope you guys here what you
want to rap about you said shoelaces
that feels kind of obvious it's there
you said fly-fishing about two weeks ago
someone over there said trout fishing
that feels a bit too close for comfort
don't be a real fool and be like well
technically you'd never try and fish for
trout with fly you wouldn't catch one
although you would wouldn't you because
it's a river fish right I know about
that so absolute node let's get
something else
what a k47
and skinning a cap night yeah I mean we
can combine those so we can have Hubble
telescope the Boston Tea Party fracking
and skinning a cap with an ak-47 all
right fine this then do you beautiful do
you say this can be a bad rap how dare
you what you look at me and go I bet he
can rap I mean you might be right we'll
find out this then lovely people of the
comedy and magic club in Hermosa Beach
to close out the show is a little thing
called a freestyle rap that has a rap
made up on the spot based entirely on
those suggestions it's gonna be pretty
good
I hope less so let's drop that beat
let's see how we do with this bunch of
stuff you give me and you can pump up a
little bit as well fracking Hubble
telescope Boston Tea Party and skinning
account with an ak-47 we'll try and
manage yeah I'm going out on the east
coast man Sam Adams not the beer from
the brewery I'm a rebel leader get to
the boats in the harbor run need to get
a box of tea and drop me in the harbor
poured it right into the sea the bridge
they be saying we gotta tax you but no
representation so we'll attack you out
of the way your whingeing pawns
your ship was yours but now we're
boarding on weekend all the teabags off
the ship's brands of tea in my country
include PG Tips typhoon but no Twinings
the flavor of the blends not to my
liking you could roll that in the water
before sorry that we can't do
Revolutionary War yeah talking about the
things I seen before turn the volume up
I need a year from 1:00 to 4:00 I'm
looking at the universe so far away
peering through a massive glass right
into space he poured it on Arrakis there
now until then I have got the hope for
the telescope is like a satellite cause
it's floating the other side of the
galaxy
Hubble he was the guy who said free will
technically not it was named after him
people at NASA space Space Station Cape
Canaveral trying to get a look with the
photos and the photon Sam back we go
whoo such an amazing thing it compared
to the rocks in Saturn's rings and the
asteroid belt howling like a dog howling
like a cat when I scale it really odd
way I don't use a knife I don't use a
sickle I don't use an icicle I use a
massive assault rifle
from Moscow it's vital signs have gone
because the guy is deceased I'm like an
evil Schrodinger say the least I'll
leave the cat dead splayed out look at
you never thought skin a cat with the
full clip but I do it yeah running it
through the brown fur around a second
going through you fully your mic it's
never on semi I'm sorry that this
section of the rap is unpleasant but
blame this guy that's what I mean why do
you boys ever nine-a or 15 who will be
Joey Harry with a magnum she will full
round right up the cat's bum it's going
round through the back and out of its
mouth the bullet passes through the cat
and shoots up a mouse it's so horrible
yeah I'm talking let me get some shale
gas so I'll start bracket Wow I'm
drilling down deep in the soil be
spoiled if you let this happen
make no mistakes if you frack you're
gonna get more earthquakes in haze we
need to ban it get in that position I'm
standing on Hollywood Boulevard a
petition in my hand but my signatures
are lacking because as you demonstrated
no one knows about fracking what
[Applause]